who do you trust the least
oh dear god oh karen i would say aaron i
probably care
the real housewives of potomac might not
agree on everything
but these ladies seem to be on the same
page about one thing
how trustworthy they find co-star karen
huger
well i'm a dale e.t sat down with gisele
bryant
robin dixon and candace dillard bassett
at bravo's tea time on the potomac event
in washington dc
where the trio played a shady game of
sip or spill
who is the shadiest potomac housewife
me who
spends the most karen
elijah tell me does she have the money
any money
i'm sure can i say that oh okay
that's the question number one okay i'm
just gonna drink who's been
i would say you on your house renovation
that would be yeah
yeah i mean you've been spending i've
been spending i've been spending yes
yeah
okay who spends the least i would say
ashley actually spends no money
you're very frugal yeah i am but then
you're spending on your house
and yes yeah and yeah robin is sneaky
with her spending
yeah she'll just bust out with something
very expensive on and i
keep her i people who drunk texts
oh wow karen i have been banned from her
drunk college is that one thing about
your relationship that you made
i do i miss that i do because they were
hilarious they were they were funny
they were always at three o'clock in the
morning now so we back together
sometimes
does she she'll like text me like dude
and it won't be worried yes
this is fresh
oh dear god oh karen and maybe you
me i super trust you
like i can see you not trusting me to
behave because i'm i may pop off
okay that's probably good okay i'll take
it back honestly for me it would be
karen because i just
don't i have a hard time believing a lot
of the stuff that comes out
you've always said that yeah you've said
it so for me it's karen i probably can't
yeah i had to think about it but yes
there's a theme here it's unfortunate
because i think
okay it's a thing who do you trust the
most oh
robin i trust robert the most
interesting
[Applause]
out of everybody yes really i call robin
about anything okay help me that's just
helpful okay that's good to know yeah
yeah robin is very intelligent and i'm
not gonna lie to nobody
right you know what i'm saying yeah i'm
going to tell the truth
i'm not going to lie i'm going to go all
the way that's very true all the way
home
who is notoriously late for everything
okay who's late for their own damn trip
okay but what i will say is if i beat
robin somewhere i'm like yes
because i'm always late who does these
things who has the best style
i really like robin's style oh thank you
yeah
and karen has a good style yeah yeah
when it's not when it's fendi not in
yeah
yeah she has good stuff i love your
style thank you if i was like your size
i would look just like you thank you
that's a compliment because i do
like to try different genres you do
you're
all over the place but it all works yes
yes yeah okay that wasn't cheap
and who has the worst style i would say
ashley i say ashley yeah
oh boy that's very sexy baby we're
not a cook but i love ashley though well
but it's just very forever 21-ish